when i was in college i worked for a  sort of accelerator and every single  business i ever worked with we would  base the strategy off of a comparable  and that helped me realize that it's  like anything you ever want to do  someone has done it 100 it's like food  and a restaurant the only thing you can  do is tweak the what i call sprinkles  you're not gonna invent the cake or the  cupcake but you might be the first one  that says what about ginger instead of  sugar you might be the first one that  says wait a minute bacon on top of a  cupcake might [ __ ] with people and they  might love it but you're not going to be  the one that creates the cupcakes